j'ai un concours un autre concours de
miss mme à vous proposer c'est dans le
19 20 de france 3 on a fait la
connaissance de débit des biquettes une
jeune alsacienne qui vient tout juste
d'être élue miss ronde univers carrément
france compte une nouvelle miss univers
dans la catégorie miss ronde lazazi
badie vient d'être sacré après des mois
de sélection et un vote sur internet
quand on regarde l'émission miss france
à la télé que quand on grandit avec
quelques rondeurs ont ce qu'on se dit
qu'effectivement c'est pas possible on
peut voir ce rêve s'éloigner mais que
effectivement c'est tout à fait à la
portée
c'est ce qu'offre le correspondant un
concours qui se déroule en ligne devrait
faire venir les pieds du monde entier il
faudrait trouver un hôtel les héberger
tu après tout ça et quand ça concerne la
femme ronde c'est déjà très compliqué de
trouver des sponsors des partenaires au
menu du body-painting reproduire une
publicité de voiture ou une photo en
maillot de bain alors des big ali m'madi
à la 33 ans donc elle a remporté ce
titre de miss ronde
elle a été couronnée deuxième dauphine
miss ronde alsace en octobre 2018 et
elle remporte cette compétition devant
une brésilienne et devant miss aquitaine
qu'est ce que c'est c'est après audrey
qu'est souris en 2018 ok c'est la
deuxième année consécutive une
alsacienne remporte miss ronde univers
qu'est ce qu'on en pense moi vous me
disiez juste avant le sujet que les miss
s'était pas votre truc
non non les miss miss france miss soit
homme ou femme peut hein pas oui oui
c'est râlant mise pour les hommes
oui mais enfin bon ben on l'a compris le
classifie à partir de là je trouve que
c'est d'une tristesse sans nom pour la
tendresse que on nous dit qu'on veut
justement que les femmes rondes grosse
ou peut appeler ça comme on veut gros ce
n'est pas un gros mot
un adjectif qualificatif avoir la même
place dans la suze tech les autres et
pourtant on fait un concours pour elle
moi je pense qu'en danse concourront
s'excluent encore plus d'un et
finalement se mêler je ne vois pas
pourquoi on doit faire un ami vous
voudriez par exemple que dans dans le
concours j'allais dire traditionnel de
miss france ou de miss univers il y est
toutes les morphologies représenter
c'est vrai que c'est un peu un monde de
bisounours mais avec un monde plus
utopique que ça et en plus je suis
désolée la tristesse du concours la
tristesse du résultat qu'est-ce qui vous
qu'est ce que vous trouvez triste là
dedans on se rend compte qu'il ya très
peu d'exposition mois pour 38e l'été je
n'ai pas entendu parler de ceux de ça et
c'est vrai qu'elle longeait le standard
pas de sponsor pas d'argent ils sont
dans un
café reprend son prix bon c'est je
trouve que ça fait pas avancer la cause
et on pensait pas qu'il ya des jeunes
filles peut-être mal dans leur peau qui
se disent bas ça je peux être aussi une
autre forme de beauté je peux être aussi
apprécié je peux être aussi porté aux
nues au travers de ça je pense que l'on
changera le regard quand il y aura
vraiment des tailles 42 44 dans tous les
magasins quand dans les reportages dans
les magazines on arrêtera de photoshop
et les femmes
lorsqu'on aura sur des podiums des
mannequins qui font pas du 34e ne
participe pas pour vous je pense que ça
danse ça ne parte accord ludivine qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
bah il a pas totalement tort mon voisin
et il a pour une fois il a pas de talent
menteur c'est vrai que ça se bouscule
pas malheureusement pour pouvoir aider
ce concours à être un petit peu mieux
exposés maintenant je vous rejoins moi
je pense que les jeunes filles qui sont
mal dans leur modèle les jeux exactement
on a besoin de modèles on a besoin d'eux
de savoir qu'on peut y arriver on a
besoin d'être mise en valeur et je pense
que ça aide dans la confiance en soi et
c'est une belle initiative qui peut être
grâce à nous aujourd'hui sera un petit
peu plus plus bizarres vivant web est
d'autant que voilà plein de mac se ruent
sur les les rayons un peu coeur du
moment surtout que c'est vrai que depuis
quelques temps on a vu notamment les
failles et les campagnes de publicité
pour l'été ont commencé et nous beaucoup
de marques
alors on va les citer un des arabes et
h&m et hautement maintenant mettre des
jeunes femmes avec des vrais rondeurs
avec des vrais ball alors ce ne sont pas
des jeunes femmes très forte certes
elles ont des rondeurs regarde mais ça
change des liens les gravats les embouts
joue bien on sent un frémissement
j'ai l'impression que c'est beau c'est
pas votre truc lennon au niveau des
marques chapeau et en effet il faut
avancer dans ce sens au niveau d'une
cérémonie comme ça c'est catastrophique
et pourquoi pas ce que c'est risible
maintenant c'est la deuxième fois qu'une
alsacienne l'emportent ça veut dire
qu'un gros problème au niveau de la
bouffe la ba ouais pas dire ça mais bon
tout de même l'espoir aux gros parce que
malheureusement il ya jeunesse des jeux
noter quand même que leurs portes deux
fois mais cette région ils voter
normalement pas d'accord en plus il fait
passer comme comme miss france qui vient
toujours du nord du nord pas de calais
ouais c'était parce que c'est une région
qui vote beaucoup ça n'a rien à nous
parce que les femmes sont belles
peut-être mais alors me dabo et pardon
mais on peut être belle et ronde mais
bien sûr avec ça ça ça n'a aucun lien en
effet mais sauf que si on commence à
faire des concours pour tous allons sur
les gens qui louche les roues et ses
exceptions sont des gens qui ont un gros
nez mais pourquoi
on crée un autre un autre vos enfants ce
n'est pas nous enfoncer
pourquoi une série d'autres concours
c'est tout simplement il y en a 1 voilà
il est fait on aime ou on n'aime pas
mais tout le mondial auteur qui sait ce
qu'est ce que tu comprends pas tout mais
l'intérêt mais fait ça dans ton jardin
on s'entend pas c'est pourquoi il y
aurait alors des demis filiforme qui
aurait le droit à une exposition
extraordinaire et de longs mois
l'exposition la preuve là on y re
démarrer au départ miss france j'imagine
c'était beau c'était un petit petit
concours et puis au fur et à mesure ça à
gagner
franchement vous êtes dur mais tous quoi
vous êtes plus toi tout seul
oui bah moi je trouve que l'intention
pardon l'intention qu'elle est bonne car
quand on a besoin d'avoir effectivement
cette représentation dans notre société
les marques effectivement comment ça va
ça va arriver ça va venir on va tout
d'un coup pouvoir intégrer tout le monde
moi j'en suis sûr maintenant c'est vrai
que la tristesse je la ressens parce
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas de soutien
n'y a pas d'argent elle récolte un
chèque de 150 euros
bon bah voilà qu il comparé d'accord ces
séries et franchement l'intention
l'intention est là l'intention est bonne
on peut pas leur jeter la pierre
franchement on trouve hyper dites nous
ce que vous en avez pensé avec le
hashtag sécu dlt de cette miss ronde
univers on a quand même univers
franchement